en france les sondages se succèdent et
la dernière enquête de l'institut tns
sofres logica pour france télévisions le
monde et france info comporte une
surprise si l'ump récente est à 27 % et
le parti socialiste en deuxième position
avec 20 %
on note qu'europe écologie passe devant
le modem avec 13,5 pour cent
d'intentions de vote ces deux partis
sont donc au coude à coude ce qui
entraîne de fortes tensions entre daniel
cohn bendit et françois bayrou
les deux hommes se sont accrochés tout à
l'heure dans l'émission à vous de juger
chez nos confrères de france 2 car
l'image inter ils étaient réunis pour
parler de l'europe sur le plateau d'à
vous de juger
le débat a viz au règlement de comptes
bloqués françois bayrou a commencé par
reprocher à daniel cohn bendit d'avoir
des relations très amicales avec le
président de la république à l'antenne
parce que ses idées monsieur cohn bendit
parce qu'il l'avait interpellé moi je
vous connais depuis longtemps on se
téléphone souvent je peux pas en dire
autant
on se téléphone souvent vous êtes venus
déjeuner trois fois à l'elysée daniel
cohn bendit voit rouge
les taux montent d'un cran je trouve ça
ignoble de ta part parce que lui-même il
exactement ce qu'il se passe quand on
est président en ligne au mieux a été
député européen midi c'est ce que
c'était et ce genre de jeu devant les
citoyens eh bien mon pote je te dis
jamais tu seras président de la
république a bien parce que t'es trop
minable pred tromilin la réponse du
leader du modem est cinglante
françois bayrou on fait alors
directement allusion au livre le grand
bazar écrit par l'ex leader de mai 68 et
dans lequel il relatait ses expériences
d'animateur dans un jardin d'enfants
je trouve ignoble moi d'avoir poussé et
justifié des actes à l'égard des enfants
que je ne peux pas accepter sûr que tu
es bien active alors là nous deux à
trois jours du scrutin la tension ne
cesse de monter entre les deux leaders
politiques particulièrement depuis que
les listes d'europe écologie dépasse
celle du modem dans certains sondages